♪ ♪ ♪
- La danse occupe une place
centrale dans la vie
de Pénélope Quirion.
♪ ♪ ♪
Six heures par semaine à répéter
les mêmes pas, les mêmes gestes.
♪ ♪ ♪
Avec des copines, tout aussi
passionnées qu'elle.
♪ ♪ ♪
Mais aussi créatives et
exigeantes soient elles,
les chorégraphies font face
à une concurrence déloyale
sitôt que la musique s'arrête.
PÉNÉLOPE QUIRION, élève de 4e
secondaire CFP des Riverains
- On a eu notre 30 minutes
puis direct on a été sur nos
téléphones. Puis on a fait
des Tiktok. Puis t'sais, oui,
on fait des Tiktok ensemble,
mais t'sais, il n'y a pas tant
de social. T'sais t'es comme :
ah, les filles, on fait-tu
un Tiktok? Puis là, après, tu le
regardes. Wow, OK, il n.n.n.n.
Tu l'enregistres. Puis ça arrête
là.
- Tiktok, une plateforme de
diffusion de courtes vidéos.
- Oui, c'est lui le meilleur.
- La dernière application
à la mode chez les adolescents.
Pénélope ne fait pas exception,
elle y passe beaucoup de temps.
- TikTok, il n'y a vraiment pas
de fin là. C'est addictif là.
♪ ♪ ♪
Il y a quelque chose dedans
qui pousse à retourner dedans.
- Est-ce que tu dirais
que ta génération est accro
au téléphone?
- Oui. Totalement! Vraiment.
Moi, je dis que sans téléphone,
on ne serait pas capables
de fonctionner.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Une dépendance qui touche
toute une génération.
Selon une étude récente,
80 % des adolescents au Québec
ont une présence sur les réseaux
sociaux. Près de 60 % d'entre
eux passent plus de 10 heures
par semaine sur internet.
Une nouvelle réalité face à
laquelle beaucoup d'enseignants
se sentent désarmés.
LIZANNE DAGENAIS, enseignante de
français, CFP des Riverains
- Avec le multimédia,
les réseaux sociaux, tout est
tellement rapide, la lenteur,
ils ont de la difficulté avec
la lenteur, maintenant.
- À ce jour, rien n'est vraiment
prévu dans le programme éducatif
québécois pour outiller les
élèves face à ce monde numérique
dans lequel ils évoluent.
- Je pense que oui, on doit
s'adapter. On doit. On le fait.
C'est sûr qu'on a besoin d'aide
pour expliquer, enseigner la
désinformation. Ça, c'est sûr.
Puis qu'on ait des ateliers,
des invités qui viennent
dans les écoles, c'est super
important.
- Cette école de Repentigny
a donc décidé de pallier
les lacunes. En offrant à ses
élèves un atelier d'information
sur Internet et les médias
sociaux pour mieux les
comprendre, pour mieux
les gérer.
- Au même rythme que les
activités sur les écrans
prennent de l'ampleur dans
nos vies, on voit en pointillé
les symptômes dépressifs
chez les adolescents.
- Car s'ils permettent
de connecter les usagers,
les médias sociaux comportent
aussi une part de danger.
EMMANUELLE PARENT, cofondatrice,
Centre intelligence émotionnelle
- Tiktok, Instagram, ils ont
un modèle économique où nous
sommes le produit; où on génère
des données et ensuite,
on est ciblés par des
publicités. D'apprendre ça
aux jeunes, ça peut permettre
de mettre des mots puis des
théories sur leurs sentiments.
Pour moi, est-ce que c'est
un problème, ou pas?
- Emmanuelle Parent est à
l'origine de cette formation.
- Laisser le téléphone d'une
heure à deux heures avant
d'aller au lit.
- Depuis sa mise en place,
l'atelier qu'elle a élaboré
s'est déjà donné des centaines
de fois dans des écoles
à travers la province.
- Des vidéos qui te donnent
le sourire, plus que d'autres
choses.
- Il y a certaines études
scientifiques qui relatent
qu'il y a des impacts négatifs
du numérique sur notre bien-
être. Puis le but avec
ces ateliers-là, c'est d'amener
les jeunes à être capables
d'avoir un esprit critique sur
leur utilisation du numérique.
- On va le dire, la vie sur
Instagram, c'est juste du fake.
- Sur Instagram, justement,
les gens ont tous un beau petitn
réalité, c'est souvent
du Photoshop ou des chirurgies
plastiques.
- Une réalisation récente,
car comme beaucoup
d'adolescentes de son âge,
Pénélope s'est longtemps
comparée aux vedettes
d'Instagram.
- J'ai commencé à m'entraîner
généralement parce que je voyais
les standards de beauté
que c'était surtout fallait que
tu sois mince; il ne
que tu aies trop de cuisses,
de ventre. Pas mal tous les gars
que moi, j'étais abonnée sur
Instagram, ils followaient
justemnenenenenenener.
Puis moi, dans ma tête, c'était
comme : Ah, il est beau, mais
comme je sais qu'il va être
intéressé seulement si j'ai
le corps de cette fille-là.
- En classe, les formatrices
se gardent bien de diaboliser
les médias sociaux.
- Ce qu'on propose,
c'est l'autodéfense numérique.
- L'idée est plutôt d'échanger
avec les élèves.
- C'est pas l'importance,
le corps, mais ton bien-être,
mais puisque tu vas tous les
jours sur les réseaux sociaux,
tu es toujours confronté à ça.
- Et de les amener à réfléchir,
à développer leur esprit
critique.
- On ne peut pas se permettre de
laisleleles jeunes sans guidance
dans cet univers numérique-là.
Les réseaux sociaux,
particulièrement, exploitent
nos vulnérabilités
psychologiques pour maintenir
notre attention. C'est pour ça
que c'est important de, quand on
est jeunes, d'apprendre c'est
quoi ces mécanismes-là puis
de reprendre le contrôle de
notre utilisation.
- Un atelier d'une heure vite
écoulé.
- Est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
personnes qui ont quelque chose
à ajouter là-dessus?
- Mais qui permet d'ouvrir
les yeux.
- La dépression sur les réseaux
sociaux, c'est plus étendu que
je croyais.
- Et d'éveiller les consciences.
- Moi, j'ai surtout appris que
il y a des manières d'utiliser
les réseaux sociaux, nos
téléphones, nos écrans surtout.
D'une façon très intelligente.
Moi, je trouve que
personnellement, j'utilisais mon
téléphone d'une manière stupide.
- Allô, j'ai remonté.
On ne casse pas la nuque.
- Aujourd'hui, Pénélope s'est
beaucoup désinvestie des médias
sociaux.
- On serre les jambons...
- Elle a entre autres zappé
les vedettes d'Instagram.
- À un moment donné, j'ai juste
fait comme : est-ce que c'est
utile d'être abonnée à eux? Non.
Fait que je me suis désabonnée.
- Elle a aussi mis de côté
l'entraînement et l'obsession
du corps parfaitsesesesese reste
sa grande passion, mais ses
motivations ont changé.
- 5, 6, 7, 8.
- Maintenant je le fais vraiment
.....
- Honnêtement quand je danse,
je sens qu'il n'y a plus rienqus
de là avec un gros sourire.